there's a chance that this was created
in a lab there's an investigation a
chance
the disease is the same name as the lab
i'm glad that you agree with me johnny
come lately but it's so disingenuous
a year and a half late ain't gonna cut
it no do not
fall for this now cnn does not have the
only journalists out there who very
rarely but
on occasion switch up the narrative
we saw this the other night with no less
a liberal than
jon stewart jon stewart went on stephen
colbert's
cbs show these guys used to work
together on comedy central at the daily
show the colbert report
now they're coming and they actually
disagreed these are both
died in the wool liberals they disagreed
because jon stewart said you know
it sure does look like the virus came
from that lab in wuhan
i think we owe a great debt of gratitude
to science science has in many ways
helped
ease uh the suffering of this
pandemic uh which was
more than likely caused by science what
do you mean by do you mean like this
perhaps
there's there's a chance that this was
created in a lab there's an
investigation a chance
well i don't i i i oh my god evidence
i'd love to hear that there's a
novel respiratory coronavirus
overtaking wuhan china what do we do
oh you know who we could ask the wuhan
novel
respiratory coronavirus lab the disease
is the same name as the lab
so think about stuart stewart actually
is pretty funny
right and he is a i don't think he's a
sophisticated political thinker
but he he points out what we have all
known for a year and a half
and this is where i want you to be very
careful do not give jon stewart credit
do not do it this is an op
this is fake do not believe this the
the purpose of this debate between jon
stewart and stephen colbert
and i'm not saying this is the purpose
that was going on in jon stewart's mind
or stephen colbert's mind i'm saying
this is the reason this is being
blown up and being talked about right
now is to create the
illusion that that parts of the media
are reasonable on this parts of the
media are
losing their using their common sense
where was jon stewart a year and a half
ago where was he
where were the mainstream media a year
and a half ago he's right
yeah oh the novel coronavirus that was
found in bats
is discovered right next to the novel
coronavirus in bats laboratory in wuhan
oh wow what a coincidence no obviously
it had something to do with the lab
when we said that a year and a half ago
the jon stewarts of the world
were either silent or were telling us
that we were crazy coup conspiracists
and big technology companies were
censoring us
and were fact-checking us and were
telling us that that was absolutely
crazy and unscientific
and we should be ostracized from society
and now they're saying well what i mean
obviously we've got common sense
obviously it had something to do with
the lab
yes that's true i'm glad that you agree
with me johnny come lately
but it's so disingenuous because you had
to cover it up a year and a half ago
because it contradicted your political
agenda and it would have put into
greater peril the 2020 election that you
were trying to win and it would have
given donald trump credit for being
obviously correct
at the time that they all said no he's a
racist he's unscientific he's a ruby's
an idiot trump
god i want to say 97 out of 100
things right on the coronavirus the
mainstream media and the dr
faucis and the democratic party got
i was going to say 3 out of 100 things
right i think it's zero out of 100
things right on the coronavirus
and now they're going to try to come in
and pretend
that they were reasonable on this as
well no thank you sorry it's not going
to work i'm glad that jon stewart is
learning and he's coming back around
and he's going to try to do better
that's fine we'll give him grace to do
that in the future
but a year and a half late ain't going
to cut it no do not
fall for this they were entirely wrong
on the virus they have new credibility
they should not be believed on any part
of it
from now on and you're going to hear a
whole lot about not just the vaccines
the vaccine passports the new
the new lockdowns for the new variants
or whatever don't believe them
don't believe them about any of it if
they hadn't squandered their credibility
day in and day out by the by the hour by
the minute
for a year and a half then maybe they
they could be believed but
as of now they cannot oh hey there oh
hey sorry
i didn't see you there you should ring
the bell right now and
you should subscribe and make sure you
get the notifications and you should
also head on over
to the apple podcast and spotify and
google play and all that to subscribe to
the audio
oh you're probably yeah right this is my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds it's available
now for pre-order but it's coming out
super duper soon so make sure you
pre-order your signed autographed
both it'll be both signed and
autographed first edition copy at
premiere collectibles you can also get
on amazon barnes noble anywhere you get
your books
see you next time
you